happy Monday everyone Game of Thrones
dropped a bunch of new teasers so let's
break it down this is a new round of the
giveaway it's for the enhanced editions
of the books all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video let's start with the biggest
step first look how big Rogan has gotten
it's almost like Daenerys is riding on
the back of a giant flying house within
the world of A Song of Ice and Fire
there's no limit to the size the Dragons
can grow they're only limited by their
food source and their ability to roam
around
that's why drogon so much bigger than
Ragle and Viserion because they were
kept in captivity for more than an
entire season now that they're out
they'll start growing again but Rogan
will always be the biggest the way they
talked about it from a production
standpoint is that the dragons are now
as big is 747 jumbo jets so I think they
were mostly talking about drogue on the
other dragons were really big but what
they're teasing here in this scene and
this is actually like a screencap from
season 7 so this is an actual scene that
we'll be watching with all these
soldiers burning in the background looks
like it's a play on the field of fire
which was an engagement during the war
of conquest where Aegon the conquerer
took his dragons balerion the black
dread MARAC sees in Veigar and fought
the gardener and lannister combined
armies they had massive forces ready to
rally against Aegon when Aegon joined
the battle instead of sending his troops
in the way you saw during the Battle of
the bastards with you know two armies
clashing against each other he flew the
dragons and they burned the field that's
why they call it the field of fire they
instantly killed 4,000 of the lannister
and Gardner troops then after the
Dragons had done their work Aegon sent
his troops in and they killed another
10,000 of their forces so that was the
end of house gardener they literally
wiped them off the map House Tyrell
which was one of the cadet branches of
house Gardner was then raised up because
they bent the knee and they became lords
of the reach hair after so it was one of
the most spectacular visually stunning
battles of Aegon's conquest it involved
all three dragons and that's what
they're teasing here so obviously
Daenerys is moving against Circe's
forces you can't really pick out the
banners that they're wearing on their
clothing so you don't know which troops
exactly these are but it just implies
it's one of the big battles in her gauge
against Cersei and it looks like this is
relatively flat plain so this isn't
happening down near Dorne but it's a
little hard to tell just because the
ground has been raised but I just I love
the idea that they're going to do a
repeat of the field of fire or at least
the battle will be inspired by that from
the books but then pretty much all the
other previews are just from stuff
that's up in the north near Winterfell
with the exception of Arya unconfirmed
but it looks like she's very close if
not at Winterfell
I think they purposefully didn't shoot
the ground that this horse was standing
on or any of the banners that are on
this wall here just so you couldn't
confirm that she was entering Winterfell
but I think that everybody would be
flipping out if she were actually there
let me know if you think that this is
actually like the opposite end of the
Kingdom and this is in King's Landing
this is a good example of the stonework
at Winterfell so it looks like she's not
there it looks like she's somewhere with
really high walls so King's Landing is a
big possibility let me know in the
comments where do you think she is here
she could still be leaving the twins
that was the last place she was taking
care of Walder Frey but most of the
northern architecture just looks a
little bit different all the stonework
like even the twins here this is what it
looks like so it doesn't look like
that's where she's at
and I think they just want to withhold
that till we get to the next trailer but
I have a feeling that when she shows up
there will be a lot more to confirm
where exactly she is in Westeros just
slowly making her way north we see Jon
Snow in the snow in the courtyard at
Winterfell looking like he's getting
ready to head out there doesn't seem to
be any particular urgency about any of
the scenes but it does seem like the
other behind the scenes images like you
see Sansa standing up here which is a
behind the scenes version of this scene
right here with her just looking down on
what's going on around the courtyard is
them getting ready to move out it looks
like Jon Snow is either dealing with the
politics of the north and the wildlings
the things that are happening around
Winterfell or he's literally getting
ready to go to Dragonstone to treat with
Daenerys in South of getting ready to
see him off but she just seems so casual
with Littlefinger about this weighing
what's happening and what's going on in
the north that it doesn't seem like
things have gotten too urgent yet
otherwise she would probably be on the
ground giving him a hug as he went away
but I just posted that video about some
of the politics that are going on up in
the
the problems that they're experiencing
in addition to the White Walkers because
that's only a small piece of the puzzle
even though that's what most of our
attentions focused on we get another
shot of tormund Giantsbane bring in
hanging out in the background and
there's another behind the scenes of
Brienne just sort of being funny walking
around the battlements at Winterfell
it sounds like she's going to stick
pretty close to Santa but I'm hoping
that if they go on any expeditions up to
the north in the wall the Brienne gets
to go to she has earth keeper the
Valyrian blade so she would come in very
handy in a white Walker fight but the
thing is is that she's pledged her
loyalty to Sansa to protect her so the
only way that she would leave her side
is if sought to order her to if she told
her to go somewhere on some mission to
do something so the other really big
thing that just happened you guys may
have noticed this is that HBO took down
their trailers a long walk one that they
released a while ago in anticipation of
a new trailers are getting ready to post
now I think it's weird that they took
down the old trailer just because
they're getting ready to post a new one
but they've done that in the past and a
lot of it just has to do with music
licensing like if there's a song that
they didn't get permission to use or
something weird happens with the dispute
they have to post a different version
they did that a couple seasons ago it
was the weirdest thing ever but whatever
who cares new Game of Thrones footage is
new Game of Thrones footage so what I
think is happening is that because
they're dropping this today it's
probably providing a preview of some of
the things that we're going to see in
the next trailer in the next couple days
if not the next week so typically HBO
makes really weird moves and things
start shifting behind the scenes right
before a big reveal so do not be
surprised if sometimes this week we get
an actual trailer in that last one we
got really wasn't even that much of a
trailer it was more of a promo with a
pop song on it the idea here is that
none of these scenes actually really
happened during season 7 they just imply
things that are going to be happening
Daenerys sitting on the throne here at
Dragonstone is probably something we'll
see but it probably won't happen like
this so the promo images that they've
released those are actual screen grabs
from scenes but the long walk promo is
just something to hype up what's coming
is not really stuff taken from scenes
that they've shot it's just something
special that they made to promote the
season but
everybody just start freaking out and
let me know just because there's only
seven episodes and they typically
include footage from all the way through
the season let me know if you think that
they're going to withhold anything from
the last couple of episodes because
there was stuff that almost went all the
way up to episode 10 in that season six
trailer last year but whatever happens
whatever post I will totally do a video
for it what's going to happen next is
there's a bunch of finales obviously if
a trailer drops tomorrow morning that
will be the next video I do so
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner alex Martinez please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything you can click
here for my new preview of what's going
on with House Stark and you can click
here for all the other season 7 trailer
videos thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight